then i came across this guy
um who i did a before the train not a
before the train wreck
playing to win uh episode let me dig it
up real quick i'll tell you what the
episode numbers it is because this is
relevant because this guy was a huge
sale in my life which is why i brought
him on uh playing the win
uh it was just before
ronan i think here there he is cameron
number 25.
so episode number 25 was about a month
ago with cameron harold
the the subtitle is the ceo whisper
so i met this guy at a conference and he
was one of the
uh speakers at um a profit 50 event i
think it was
where i was getting a award and he was
talking about
culture and how he um went through such
hyper growth with
a franchise company that he built i
think they went from something like
um four or five million dollars a year
in annual sales to well over 106 and
they added so many franchises
during that period of time is one of
these like super success stories where
your jaw just drops and you're like wow
that's pretty good that's pretty
impressive that guy has things and knows
stuff that i don't know
how do i learn more from him and i can't
remember if he offered it at the end of
his talk but i just um
i grabbed his i don't have his dvds here
they're actually in the other room but i
grabbed his dvd package so i bought that
for like 100 bucks or whatever he was
selling them for
dvds are kind of old school for those of
you that don't know what they are
ask your mom and dad if you're younger
but anyway
picked up his uh package on pr
and i hired him as a business coach
a lot of people will uh bark and snap
at uh hiring somebody to coach you
but i think that's a big mistake success
leaves clues and anybody that's
got the skill set that you want to learn
from
you need to get in front of them you
need to spend time with them somehow
whether you donate your time uh to help
them level up
uh tim ferriss has a great story about
that in one of his early either early
blogs or it might have been
even been in the four-hour work week um
but i hired cameron
you know cameron is a coach and he was
um he wasn't cheap he was about 3 500
bucks at the time
i think for an hour uh per month um
and i went with him for a good number of
months i think it was about
9 or 10 maybe 11 months or so it was
close to a year anyway
but he was a sale in my life you know he
costs a lot of money but the value that
i got in return was
easily 10 times greater than what i paid
for his time
and again you know the business went
through another hyper growth cycle after
that
you